Let us look at another example of decision tree learning. Here is a data set of
people who go to the beach, and some of them get sunburned, and
others don't. In this data set, there are nine examples and
each example is characterized by four features, hair, height, age and lotion.
Once again, how can we construct an optimal decision tree that they classify all
of those examples? One possible idea is to discriminate first on hair color.
Hair color classifies all of these known examples into three categories,
brown, red and blonde. The interesting thing about the choice of hair color is
that in the case of brown, all of these sunburnt cases are negative. People with
brown hair apparently don't get sunburned. In case of all the red haired people,
there is sunburn. So hair color is a good choice for picking as a feature to
discriminate on because it classifies things in such a way that some of
the categories have only negative instances and no positive instances. And
some of the categories are only positive instances and no negative instances.
Of course, that still leaves blonde-haired people. In this case,
there are both some positive instances and some negative instances, and
therefore, will need another feature to discriminate between the positive and
the negative instances. Here, lotion might be the second feature that we pick.
Lotion now classifies the remaining examples into two categories, some people
used lotion, other people did not. Those who used lotion did not get sunburnt.
Those who did not use lotion did get sunburn. Once again, these are all
negative instances. These are consisting of only positive instances.
Thus, in this decision tree, simply by using two features, we were able
to classify all of these nine examples. This is a different decision tree for
this same data set. But because we use a different order, therefore, now we have
to do more work. This decision tree is less optimal than the previous one.
We could have chosen a different set of features in a different order. Perhaps,
we could first discriminate on height then on hair color and age. In this case,
we did a much bushier tree. Clearly, this tree is less optimal than this one.
Note the trade off with the decision tree learning and
discrimination tree learning that we covered in case-based reasoning.
Decision tree learning leads to more optimal classification trees. But
there is a requirement. You need all the examples right up front. Discrimination
tree learning may lead to suboptimal trees, but you can learn incrementally.